[Music]
in would you do it news yep always
depends submitted by chicken oh no
chicken a Netflix special tries to trick
people into murder huh duck are you
talking about oh I wouldn't do that you
wouldn't you wouldn't murder
I wouldn't trick people oh that's me but
you would murder you just won't try to
keep murder he looks like a murdering
type no just mercy killing you would
hire someone else to murder who does
David know oh yeah because he's like
that's what dictators do and I feel like
he's always trying to figure out how to
be a dictator that's one of my guilty
pleasures his lights I kind of like
watch other dictators and wish I was
then yeah
dictators never do can you read my
income no but I should cuz I feel like I
should study you know my the only reason
I know that book is because American
History X that for American history in
school uh one of my friends on Facebook
put as one of his favorite books mine
caught that he's ever read right it
wasn't that it was more like [ __ ] you
do not read and so I literally wrote on
his Facebook thing I was like take that
[ __ ] off alright I think it's like why I
was like you don't read because I read
that book alright cool what's it about
this bull deleted that [ __ ] about I've
read the Communist Manifesto in high
school and it was so dense I didn't know
what it was I mean I mean like I know
you know Marx was the creator of it so I
bought the book and I read it and I read
the whole thing but it was like reading
the Bible at the time I didn't get it so
I bought like one that was condensed it
was like communist mountain manifesto
for dummies but it's not that one it's
like a real shortened version and I
understood that and I was like oh this
is dope you ever read The Art of War
yes that's a really interesting book
because everything is like in metaphor
or like you're not a disciple not my god
yeah and in the way that they spoke back
then it's like if if you have the the
bird and the sea and the land or like
whatever and it's like you got to make
sense of it so I got a version where a
professor
yeah in today's that kind of how this
was worth like it wasn't so direct like
this is how you're gonna murder but it
was like in like codes and like well so
this next look special it's called the
push and it's where a British
illusionist named Darren brown tries to
conquer Spiegel into like pretty much
cornering them into committing murder Oh
in the video in this show you guys a
trailer of it okay what do you call it
um illusionist okay not called magicians
anymore no no there's another one what
about the hip hip miss hip no tit
hypnosis hypno hypnotist good he just
said that you were putting the emphasis
on the wrong places and he kept doing
all the examples but he was so stuck on
like figuring out the differences
between them that I was the only one
laughing what's the difficulty when I
have a part of Miss yeah that's an anime
Mentalist Mentalist illusionists and
hypnotist yeah well the Mentalist that I
was working this event that I was at
he also hypnotized people so I don't
know if there are two separate things or
if they're intertwined no no but it was
pretty crazy cuz like even Steve who's
like the most cynical of people super
super cynical of that stuff he was like
mind blown by it yeah because like this
guy did some stuff where like I don't
even there's just like no illusion or a
trick that he just like like your mind
yeah I don't know I explained it like he
would have two people look at each other
right and then he'd be like focus on
this person and then he'd have one
person close their eyes and then he's
like okay I'm gonna have you close your
eyes and if you feel anything let me
know then he would brush the other
person with their eyes open he brushed
their nose with a tissue and the person
with their eyes closed would be like oh
I feel brushing
my nose and like they would do so she
knows how to turn on the collective
conscious yeah that's awesome because
they did this study where they showed a
bunch of people this ad in Australia and
then they you know played the ad again
in the UK in a study group and then
they're like I've seen this before
somewhere whatever yeah what's happening
in the comments people are out for every
single video they're like is this a real
blood well we just talked about the most
similar news like did you collect it is
that how the whole world is turning into
a [ __ ] Oh like their consciousness
bitching out together Oh collective
business yeah sensitiveness Oh
collective legs this will keep though
here's a trail everybody got that huh
collective what laziness yeah I would
love that
cuz if everyone worked less then you
don't have to work exactly then I would
be an overachiever right now yes no but
then it gets harder to compete cuz then
it's just like my machine is better than
your machine and then you got all got
shooting machines like if we all have
bows and arrows then if I have a handgun
I literally I have like a laser cannon
yeah but if everyone has automatic
weapons then I need some [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] to be everybody that's what I'm
saying it gets harder to compete and
humans naturally want to compete so no
one's ever lazy they just compete with
their laziness and then it's just gonna
get harder
good point let's watch that trailer yeah
here we go I don't need a compete I'm
just lazy there you go let's do it this
is called the push what is it wrong I
want to talk to the ocean out you did to
talk to your chin here you helped them
set these completed
Khris Khris alkaloid argos paid the
bills of ringer bite
chris is enmeshed in a web of lies and
that's important
I need him to feel like there's only one
way out when he's told to commit murder
my name is Darren brown and the question
we're considering is simple can we be
manipulated through social pressure to
commit murder
a hundred percent yes um do people come
younger the cancerous tick Molly's 70
actors will be paying out a meticulously
planned and rehearsed scenario to
manipulate this man who has no idea he's
being filmed that's what you do isn't
mayonnaise gotta make sure you go to
jail this show is about how readily we
hand over authorship of our lives
every day just one big consensual
compliance be used to make someone push
a living breathing human being to their
death welcome to the post
dan that's just crazy oh I don't even
need people to tell me I'll kill
somebody that's it I'm pretty sure they
had one of us on the show the show would
end in three seconds who do you need me
to kill this is a scenario if you push
in many people all right you-you-you-you
well if you get a normal person with Gil
to do yeah yeah I would not push anyone
as soon as they go this guy's a
millionaire he's gonna my he's already
off he's got it up he slapped your
mother well off you go kill the host
because I don't want any witnesses damn
we got some psychopaths in here or I
might I don't know I think I might call
the police in the middle of it all and
turn on them like an answer from one of
us I feel like I wouldn't expect you to
do that well because I mean it depends
on this grip on reality pretty well it
depends on the circumstances right like
I don't just want to kill people
I do but I don't I want to get away with
it right so if I if I was it like in the
military or whatever and you know that
nothing can happen to you I think it
makes people into a different person
because we have military friends who go
out and when they're doing their job
which is to kill people
they don't see it the same way when they
come back to civilian life they're not
killing people on a regular but over
there it's fun for them some of them
actually love their job to the point
where they're like asking their superior
officer like hey can I just get that
civilian guy walking across civilian
yeah yeah it is that's also that the
type of war were fighting now another
like urban warfare so sometimes it's
hard to tell like if that person the
terrorist or that person is a civilian
because jerez the life civilians what
about backfired on them and he kills
himself like cuz he can't handle the
pressure
yeah
like too much guilt and they're like I I
don't I can't do it and like if it's up
to me like they could just kill
themselves I think that I'm worried
about the most is like people getting
pushed to that part of their brain where
they can't get out of it anymore like I
feel like it's a PTSD like [ __ ] like
really traumatizing type of yeah maybe
the Mentalist Darren brown here pull
them back like if he can push him there
you could probably slowly figure out a
way to pull him back possibly but I mean
how long is that process gonna take I
use the second season yeah I kinda would
want to be on this show just to see what
my limits and like just how I would
react and their extreme pressure but
then I'd be scared that I could never
get out of that face in my head anymore
and I'm like constantly like either
trying to kill or trying to run away
from [ __ ] he doesn't know you signed up
for everything you who doesn't know I
don't it doesn't know yeah like they set
it all up around here I'd be [ __ ] yeah I
would be fought it's like a double-blind
experiment you know what it's I know
feels like it's like we're gonna do an
experiment about what kind of TVs you
like but behind that it's actually
they're testing for something else yeah
because if once you know the experiment
you're n you you is you're gonna buy it
answers yeah I just would not work on me
whatsoever like a hundred percent he is
of everything and it turns out being the
complete opposite no because in order
for this to happen you have to get me
out of bed first
that's good I mean look all we need is a
good restaurant like Slater sales oh I
feel like I would try to run before
anything that's exactly yeah like I like
I'll go to the bathroom I'll be like
yeah I'll go get the pills and I'll just
[ __ ] be gone out of that building
dude you would never make the cut then
like
users are like interviewing people like
novice guys like people don't know I'm
actually very non-confrontational they
could get David if they set it up like
like a regular day no like like right
here right now like this is the setup to
it and then one of us get killed or
something happens and then it's like
it's gonna [ __ ] with your daily life
because you don't ever know what's being
filmed in order to [ __ ] with my daily
life I have to put the effort to think
about it it's deleted something like
this happened out in Malaysia our buddy
is a part of a radio station out there
and they're interviewing us and then
they do these like weekly pranks so me
and Bart we were being interviewed and
in the middle of it the the radio
station manager comes in and they get
into a fight with the host and it was
our friend
right and then during the whole time
they were worried that we would get up
and start like whaling on them but the
opposite happened which is like we
Christmas calm the whole time and we're
like you know we'll pay for the mistake
because they're like you messed up the
airtime you cost us like six thousand
dollars of ad revenue this and that and
everyone thought that we were gonna turn
around and start like beating down the
radio station manager and the opposite
happened is we're really calm and boring
in real life started I started thinking
about it because the fight was really
petty and then that guy threw something
our friend yeah Nozick oh [ __ ] if it's
gonna go there if they're not gonna let
us leave unless we pay oh my I'm not the
[ __ ] some fools up but then until then I
were just chillin I'm like this is
really crazy but they did a really good
job cuz I was really full cause I
thought surreal I'm like oh my that's
why you guys are third world country
instead of feeling offended I think
that's worse than whaling I then did
just look at them as creatures I'm just
like oh look at these ingrates yeah
that's exactly what happened these
people with this series are they like
are they like backlash or what
no it's just that they recently they
recently premiered this trailer and so
everyone's talking about it like oh man
that's creepy wanna watch I wanna watch
no it seems like this takes place in the
UK but it's on Netflix I get the Netflix
special I'm Tana watch don't watch
I'm sold Sam Wow depending on how it's
constructed you don't know like we could
only speculate now but then unless
you're there
[ __ ] I'll be like oh [ __ ] the plot
thickens I would I want to know how much
they constructed light it could be like
he's been with for the past three years
it's just an actress oh I'm actually an
actress and I've never came that's
[ __ ] up you're terrible in bed thank
you
[Music]